bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur Public Sénat lundi prochain le 18
janvier François Hollande présentera les
détails de son plan d'urgence pour
l'emploi l'emploi et le chômage restent
les préoccupation numéro 1 des Français
c'est dans ce contexte que le Sénat
cette semaine a adopté à l'unanimité une
proposition de loi socialiste issue de
l'Assemblée nationale une proposition de
loi
d'expérimentation visant à résorber le
chômage de longue durée un dispositif
qui s'inspire d'une initiative d'ATD
carmonde qui va permettre d'embaucher
pendant 5 ans dans 10 territoires
volontaires des chômeurs de longue durée
c'est-à-dire inscrit à Pôle-Emploi
depuis plus d'un an en CDI ils seront
embauchés dans des entreprises des
économie sociale et solidaire avec une
aide financière apportée par l'État aide
également apportée par les collectivités
territoriales qui l'auront proposé enfin
par des organismes publics et privés
toutes ces aides étant regroupé dans un
fond spécifique alors vous allez le voir
si un certain nombre de groupes
politiques au Sénat ont jugé
l'initiative limitée cela NES a pas
empêché de tous voter favorablement à
cette initiative tout de suite donc
retour au débat c'était un mercredi dans
l'hémicycle on passe à l'article 1er la
parole est à Monsieur Roland Courteau
merci madame la Présidente très
rapidement puisque beaucoup de choses
ont été dites nul besoin d'y insister
chacun sait ici à quel point le chômage
de longue durée est une véritable plie
et une vraie souffrance pour celles et
ceux qui en sont victimes c'est en effet
une épreuve violente dans un parcours de
vie un véritable piège qui enferme la
personne touchée dans un engrenage
pouvant conduire à la précarité dès lors
contre ce fléo tenace nous devons être
attentifs à toute innovation à toute
proposition à toute solution car chaque
dispositif chaque proposition chaque
innovation peut apporter sa pierre pour
assurer le retour à l'emploi et en fait
d'innovation cette proposition emporte
une de taille avec le lancement d'une
expérimentation permettant de réinsérer
dans l'emploi des chômeurs de longue
durée pour un coûte qui pourrait être
nul pour les finances publiques
l'innovation est réelle et sans
précédent et c'est ce qui me séduit dans
cette proposition de loi permettre de
faire embaucher en CDI par des
entreprises de l'économie sociale et
solidaire des travailleurs rencontrant
des difficultés d'accès à l'emploi et
faire financer en partie ces nouveaux
emplois par des sommes économisées sur
les aides financières à loué à ces
chômeurs de longue durée il y a là une
piste particulièrement intéressante qui
mérite d'être emprunté réorienté ou
redéployer les économies réalisé par les
organismes publics grâce à la sortie des
personnes actuellement au chômage de
longue durée ne négligeons pas une telle
innovation et saluons l'auteur de cette
proposition de loi et surtout comme cela
a été dit à TD carmonde qui est à
l'origine et les associations
caritatives qui ont travaillé le sujet
chaque proposition peut apporter sa
pierre dans la lutte contre ce fléo qui
est le chômage de longue durée chômage
de longue durée qui touche rappelons-le
plus d'un chômeur sur deux le travail ne
manque pas les besoins existent et sont
nombreux cette proposition de loi et les
pistes qu'elle suggèrent sont bien la
preuve que non effectivement comme cela
a été dit décidément nous n'avons pas
tout essayé contre le chômage faisons
donc preuve d'audace et d'imagination
voilà en tout cas un texte qui va dans
le sens de l'intérêt général et qui
prend réellement en compte la notion de
droit à l'emploi tel qu'il figure dans
le préambule de la Constitution de
1946 merci merci beaucoup alors nous
passons à l'examen de trois amendements
et de trois sous-amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune le
1emer le 8 rectifié est présenté par
Monsieur Jean sanatas vous avez la
parole chers collègues merci madame la
présidente madame la ministre cet
amendement est de précision et
sécurisation juridique il indique
notamment le nombre de territoires qui
seront concernés par
l'expérimentation soit 10 au total dans
un premier temps il conviendra de
veiller selon l'avis d'ailleurs du du
CZE à l'équilibre de la répartition
entre les territoires ruraux péri
urbains urbains et en n'oubliant pas les
autres ma on obtiendra ainsi un spectre
assez large des activités possibles et
des résultats en fonction de de toutes
les situations démographiques et
économique merci beaucoup le
sous-amendement 64 c'est monsieur gaboti
qui le
présente très
bien oui c'est un sousamendement sur sur
la durée qui vise de réduire
l'expérimentation de 5 ans à 3 ans non
pas pour
amoindrir la portée du texte mais au
contraire poursuivre une expérimentation
sur 5 ans réduit l'ambition de ce texte
en effet il y a des expériences qui sont
déjà engagées le nombre de territoires
est limité tout le monde reconnaît que
effectivement c'est une
expérimentation petit format malgré tout
et
donc cette modification de calendrier
répond à un souci de réactivité pour
évaluer l'expérimentation proposée par
la loi et l'étendre le plus rapidement
possible si l'expérimentation est
positive et à l'inverse effectivement
mettre fin à cette expérimentation si le
dispositif savait inopérant donc c'est
pour donner plus de force plus de
réactivité à la loi comment dire à un
public de chômeurs de longue durée qu'on
va faire une expéation une
expérimentation et que on va faire ça
sur 5 ans à la vitesse je dirais où
notre monde et notre société évolue je
trouve que c'est un un délai qui est
beaucoup trop long et qui va à
l'encontre des intentions même de ce
texteci le sous-amendement 60 c'est
monsieur vanandlerambert qui le
présente Madame la Ministre euh il
s'agit avec cet
amendement de recourir dans le cadre de
l'expérimentation d'élargir ce cette
expérimentation au secteur marchand et
notamment au petites entreprises bien
sûr on comprend parfaitement que
l'intention première vise l'économie
sociale et solidaire je l'ai dit tout à
l'heure dans la discussion générale
parce que ces entreprises connaissent
bien les publics concernés mais
l'ouverture au secteur marchand se
justifie aussi parce qu'en cas de
généralisation du dispositif celui iici
aura vocation à s'appliquer à tout à
tous les types d'entreprisees au-delà de
l'économie sociale et solidaire et qui
convient donc de
l'expérimenter je rappelle qu'on est
dans une phase expérimentale et donc si
on ne teste pas que pourrons-nous
conclure donc voilà la raison de cette
ouverture que nous souhaiterions plus
large qu'elle n'est prévue merci le
sous-amendement 61 madame
David oui merci madame la Présidente
c'est à notre tour un amendement de
précision que nous voulons apporter dans
la rédaction telle que proposé par notre
rapporteur auquel par ailleurs nous
adhérons parfaitement mais simplement
nous voulons préciser que les activités
économiques créées seraient des
activités économiques pérennes c'est
plus dans le le but évidemment
d'affirmer ça dans l'objectif de de ce
dispositif qui est mis en place
puisqueen effet le projet de
l'association
porté donc dans cette PPL consiste à
proposer un emploi en contrat à durée
indéterminée c'est donc bien un CDI à
hauteur au minimum du SMIG puisque c'est
le temps c'est le le droit commun du
travail et que le temps choisi serait
adapté à la personne qui tiendrait cet
emploi C l'emploi est donc considéré
comme un élément émancipateur social et
non seulement comme un élément
économique donc notre amendement
complète simplement le texte en
précisant que cette expérimentation
offre des des activités économiques
pérennes alors ce matin on nous a
rétorqué que nous n'étions pas de vin
que nous n'avions pas de boule de
cristal et que nous pouvions pas
prétendre avant même de les avoir créé
que ces activités économiques seraient
pérennes bien évidemment mes chers
collègues mais en tout cas c'est
l'objectif que nous devons poursuivre de
permettre au travers de ce dispositif
que les activités économiques qui seront
créées soit de véritables activités écon
omque et donc qu'elle soit pérenne merci
beaucoup
l'amendement 55 rectifié monsieur van
lenberg oui c'est le même que le
sous-amendement numéro 60 que j'ai
défendu tout à l'heure donc je considère
qu'il est déjà défendu merci beaucoup
l'amendement 43
rectifié monsieur Chassin le
présente Madame présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le Président même le
rapporteur mes chers collègues vous avez
dit Madame le Ministre que le chômage
c'est la peur d'être en marge oui c'est
tout à fait vrai et le droit au travail
est est fondamental donc même si cette
loi est modeste je soutiendrai ce projet
de loi même s'il doit être amélioré je
pense que le le Sénat est doit aussi
pouvoir améliorer le le texte bon j'ai
j'ai moi-même pour ma commune et
peut-être ma communauté de commune fait
acte de candidature au niveau du du
préfet de de la corise mais je pense que
on peut alors je pense que ce qui est
intéressant aussi et ça a été dit par
certains la mobilisation de de local et
l'initiative locale je pense que ça
aussi c'est un plus notamment dans des
territoires de petite paille de petite
taille mais comme l'a dit monsieur
valenberg je pense que effectivement ce
texte doit être amélioré parce
que il faut aussi pouvoir que toutes les
entreprises puissent participer à
l'expérimentation en effet les
entreprises de
deses économie sociale et solidaire
représentent qu'une partie minime des
employeurs et il paraît difficile de
réduire durablement le chômage de longue
durée uniquement avec les entreprises
l'économie sociale et solidaire donc une
aide par une exonération par exemple de
charge social pendant la période de
l'expérimentation permettrait d'inciter
les entreprises du secteur marchands qui
sont volontaires
euh et qui ont la fibre sociale parce
que c'est vrai que ils ont une démarges
qui sont très faibles permettrai
d'embaucher des des chômeurs de longue
durée
euh je pense que par cette exonération
des charges sociales pendant 5 ans les
entreprises embaucheraient plus
facilement cette catégorie de chômeurs
cet allergement leur permettrait de
prendre du temps pour former le salarié
à l'activité de l'entreprise et
laisserait à CELI à celui-ci le temps de
s'adapter à l'entreprise et de retrouver
un rythme de l'emploi et ensuite je
pense que effectivement l'emploi serait
pérennisé et peut-être aussi bien ou
mieux que dans l'économie sociale et
solidaire voilà l'objet de mon
amendement merci beaucoup alors avis de
Madame euh la rapporteur sur cette série
d'amendements et
sous-amendements merci madame la
Présidente alors pour le sous-amendement
euh réduction de de 5 à 3 ans de la
réduction de la durée maximale de
l'expérimentation euh nous en avons
débattu en commission ce matin euh c'est
vrai que le texte prévoit une durée
maximale de de 5 ans en laissant en
vertu de l'article 7 le Fond national
libre d'interrompre avant la durée de 5
ans l'expérimentation qu'elle soit
concluante ou qu'elle soit décevante
nous espérons bien entendu qu'elle sera
concluante et ce qui permettrait de de
raccourcir le de raccourcir le délai par
contre le fait de de
remplacer 5 par par 3 nous paraît être
un peu court pour permettre notamment à
certains territoires qui sont peut-être
pas encore très avancés dans le dans le
dans
l'expérimentation de pouvoir de pouvoir
être être évalué convenablement
donc moi j'avais proposé initialement un
avis défavorable à cette à cette
proposition mais la commission des
affaires sociales a donné un avis
favorable ce
matin pour le sous-amendement 60 de
Monsieur
vanenberg qui est équivalent à celui de
de Monsieur Chassin qui vise à ouvrir
l'expérimentation au-delà de
euh
de du secteur de l'économie sociale et
solidaire à l'ensemble des entreprises
situées sur le sur le territoire nous
n'avons pas eu l'occasion de de de
l'examiner mais nous avions un un
amendement similaire ce matin et la
commission a donné un avis
défavorable pour le sous amendement 61
euh de Madame David qui
prévoit l'obligation pour l'entreprise
de développer des activités économiques
pérennes j'y étis pour ma part favorable
mais la Commission n'a pas suivi mon
avis et a donné un avis défavorable
estimant que l'amendement était
superflu pour l'amendement numéro 8 qui
euh je m'arrête là ou je vais jusqu'au
jusqu'au 8 alors pour l'amendement
numéro 8 qui est un amendement de de
clarification de l'objet de
l'expérimentation la commission a donné
un avis
favorable vous continuez voilà Contin je
continue sur l'ensemble oui vous faites
l'ensemble alors le le 55 donc qui
rejoint l'amendement le sous-amendement
de Monsieur van lorenberg c'est un avis
à nouveau
défavorable et pour celui de Monsieur
Chassin 43 qui est le même argumentaire
que celui de Monsieur van laurenberg
l'avis est défavorable également merci
beaucoup alors avis du gouvernement
madame la ministre sur cette série
d'amendement et sous-amendement alors
euh s'agissant du sous-amendement 64
euh sur le délai de passer de 5 ans à 3
ans j'entends bien sûr le fait que il y
a une forte impatience aussi et ça a été
exprimé ici sur tous les bancs
de cette assemblée cette volonté
justement d'aller assez vite puisqu'il y
a en effet des territoires qui sont
prêts et par rapport à la préparation de
certains territoires il serait légitime
que nous puissions avoir un bilan plus
rapidement néanmoins dans ce projet il y
a également la possibilité de pour les
entreprises qui seront conventionnées de
développer des activités qui soient
pérennes des activités et des emplois et
donc il me semble que si nous voulons
donner toutes les chances à ce projet de
réussir nous devons donner le temps aux
entreprises de se développer pour que
les activités développées se pérénisent
c'est un petit peu ce qui avait été
indiqué dans le casadre des échanges
autour au C c'est aussi ce comportai des
représentants d'ATD carmondte alors moi
même si je partage bien sûr le souci de
réactivité c'est vrai que on est en
train ensemble de décider une
expérimentation et nous avons hâte
d'avoir les résultats de cette
expérimentation mais il me sem plus
raisonnable de conserver une durée de 5
ans le bilan débutant 18 mois avant la
fin de
l'expérimentation donc c'est un avis
défavorable s'agissant de l'amendement
de Monsieur van lberg et de monsieur qui
est identique à celui de Monsieur
Chassin il m'apparaît également nous
avons eu aussi cet échange à l'Assemblé
nationale sur entre les entreprises
privées et les entreprises de l'esss il
me semble important de conserver le
bénéfice de cette expérimentation aux
entreprises de l'USSS qui ne se limite
pas d'ailleurs l' SS ne se limite pas
qu'au secteur non marchand l' SS et
aussi dans le secteur marchand je crois
qu'il est important aussi ici de le
rappeler parce que l'esss est aussi une
façon d'entreprendre un modèle de
développement économique qui est adapté
à tous les domaines de l'activité
humaine qui soit marchand non marchand
et la ligne de partage qu'on peut dire
entre leesss et les autres entreprises
est marqué par l'adhésion à C certaines
valeurs un but poursuivi autre que le
partage des bénéfices la recherche d'une
utilité sociale une gouvernance
démocratique des bénéfices
majoritairement affecté au développement
des activités de l'entreprise et je veux
vraiment faire la distinction entre
cette expérimentation et on n'est pas là
en train de tester un nouveau dispositif
en direction des petites entreprises un
dispositif où on a des débats par
ailleurs bien sûr sur l'aide TPE jeune
apprentis sur l'aide TPE au première
embauche il y a d'autres dispositifs
pour pour soutenir les entreprises mais
je crois que ici on est quand même dans
un objectif qui est propre à l' SS qui
contribue contre les exclusion
économique et social pour la le maintien
de la cohésion territoriale et donc pour
moi il me semble qu'il est intéressant
que l'expérimentation s'oriente
uniquement en direction de vers elle et
donc j'ai mets un avis défavorable à
votre amendement s'agissant de
l'amendement de Madame David
euh je note l'avis de la commission des
affaires sociales mais je partage aussi
le souet de procurer des emplois
durables au demandeurs d'emploi
bénéficiaire de l'expérimentation il
s'agit bien d'une expérimentation ici
pour sortir de la précarité et viser
l'insertion professionnelle des
demandeurs d'emploi de longue durée et
donc pour ma part j'ai met un avis
favorable à cette amélioration
rédactionnelle qui est portée dans cet
amendement
l'avis sur l'amendement 8 oui sur l'AM
l'amendement 8 je trouve qu'il améliore
la rédaction de l'article 1er notamment
qui fixe le champ de l'expérimentation à
10 territoires je je partage en outre
votre préoccupation de ne pas fragiliser
le modèle économique des entreprises
créées dans le cadre de cette
expérimentation par des règles de non
concurrence qui serait trop stricte et
donc j'ai mets un avis favorable si nous
avons encore de amendements pour votre
avis ah c'était des
oui
d'accord alors nous allons passer au
vote nous allons commencer par le
sous-amendement 64 qui je le rappelle a
un avis favorable de la commission et
défavorable du gouvernement qui souhaite
intervenir alors monsieur gabouti monsur
oui merci madame la présidente madame la
ministre simple simple remarque en
réponse à madame le rapporteur la
rapporteur
euh objectjecter que on pourra
effectivement Inter que le fond pourra
interrompre le dispositif en cours a
quand même l'inconvénient d'introduire
une une incertitude hein sur le
fonctionnement du 10 dispositif quand on
s'engage dans une voie comme ça on
s'engage sur des choses claires alors
c'est 3 ans ou 5 ans c'est pas quelque
chose d'aléatoire qu'on pourrait
interrompre en fonction de critères et
cetera donc je vous crée c'est une
réponse d'insécurité par rapport au
dispositif quant à la réduction de la
durée je pense qu'elle va vraiment dans
l'esprit dans lequel ce texte a été
voulu sans prendre en compte les
nécessités de notre époque vous voulez
expérimenter une une start-up à vocation
sociale et vous lui donner le rythme de
natelage à bœ
monsieur Mouillet
oui madame président ministre de deux
remarques de façon générale sur à la
fois la dimension économie sociale et
solidaire et à la fois sur la durée tout
d'abord parce que là je je parle
également en ayant vu de de très près le
le montage de l'expérimentation et on se
rend compte qu'aujourd'hui sur les
territoires les structures qui sont
mobilisées pour recruter les demandeurs
d'emploi de longue durée sont avant tout
des structures qui s'occupent de
l'insertion et souou de fait que la très
grande majorité je vux pas dire la
totalité mais la très grande majorité
des structures qui s'occupent d'inertion
sont avant tout des entreprises de
l'économie sociale et solidaire pourquoi
parce que on est principalement sur des
métiers qui sont peu aujourd'hui qui ne
sont pas rentables et c'est important
par que parce que sur le territoire en
parallèle les entreprises regardent de
très près cette expérimentation et
oncune crainte c'est que on met en place
un système concurrentiel donc on peut
pas d'un côté écouter entend nos
entreprises traditionnelles qui
participent qui observent qui regardent
de très près puisque on espère justement
qu' nombre de demandeurs d'emploi seront
amenés à basculer dans les autres
sociétés on peut difficilement écouter
d'un côté les entreprises
traditionnelles et se dire finalement il
faut que ça soit des des métiers qui
sont qui soi pas rentables donc je faut
être très clair aujourd'hui seul sur les
territoires à mon avis les structures
d'un saasson ont la capacité de démarrer
de démarrer l'expérimentation donc ça
renvoie le débat sur les les les
l'économie sociale et solidaire ensuite
concernant la durée même chose lorsqu'on
parle avec ceux qui se sont engagés
qu'est-ce qui se passe on se rend compte
que le temps de mettre en place le
dossier contacter les chemurs de longue
durée mobiliser les partenaires là vous
avez auamo entre 18 mois et 2 ans si
vous faites le tour de l'ensemble des
acteurs et ensuite vous mettez en place
le la structure en partant de métiers
non rentable pour les rendre rentables
donc je pense qu'en matière de durée je
suis partagé à la fois je comprends
l'argument de dire il faut aller vite
parce qu'on a besoin DEAT proanc mais
dans la réalité des choses ben les
choses sont beaucoup plus compliquées et
nous thorisons sur le terrain je peux
vous assurer que les choses sont un peu
différentes merci Monsieur
cadiic merci madame la présidente madame
les ministre
euh éradiquer le chômage de longue durée
rien de moins vous n'arrivez pas à
inverser la courbe du chômage et pour
mieux masquer cet échec on lance une
expérimentation de résorption du chômage
de longue durée on évaluerait le
résultat fin 2019 ou début 2020 à mi-
mandat du prochain Président de la
République qui sera élu en 2017 qui peut
croire que c'est avec une telle loi que
disparaîtra le chômage de longue
durée faire une loi pour faire une
expérimentation ça choque personne
encore une loi où est le pacte de
simplification quelle loi
supprimons-nous pour compenser cette
nouvelle loi le rapporteur a reconnu que
de N nombreux points restent à éclaircir
quant au fonctionnement et au
financement de cette
expérimentation cela sera donc fait par
d'autres la belle affaire moi je
souhaiterais que l'état d'urgence soit
déclaré pour lutter contre le
chômage tout le monde semble se réjouir
de cette loi qui sera donc évaluée en
2019 et qui ne sera valable que pour
seulement 10 territoires pour les autres
ils attendront
2021 les électeurs eux vous évalueront
en 2017 et je crains qu'il n'est pas
votre patience en tout cas pour ma part
je n'ai pas la vôtre je ne voterai pas
ce texte qui laisse tant de chômeurs sur
le bas côté bien monsieur Chassin a
demandé la parole comment il s'appelle
notre sénateur là de la Réunion
simplement si vous voulez pour parler du
secteur
marchand madame la ministre vous m'avez
bien indiqué que l'économie sociale
solidaire était du secteur marchand je
suis tout à fait d'accord et donc je je
pense que dans certains territoires
notamment celui que je connais le mieux
qui est isolé alors je suis d'accord
avec Monsieur Cadix tout ça c'est pas la
padacée c'est pas avec ça qu'on va
régler le chômage mais pour moi c'est un
petit plus pour certains territoires et
il faut absolument rien négliger donc
moi j'y suis favorable et ce que je
voudrais faire prendre et évoluer c'est
que l'artisanat le commerce dans des
territoires ruraux isolé à des marges
très limitées et je pense qu'il serait
bien peut-être pas dans un premier temps
mais dans quand même assez rapidement de
pouvoir le faire évoluer vers le secteur
marchand peut-être sur un autre domaine
ce que j'ai exprimé tout à l'heure
c'était simplement de diminuer les char
soci dans ce secteur pour pour le
secteur marchand et je pense que ça ça
serait une évolution très positive merci
Monsieur verg a demandé la parole
oui madame la Présidente mes collègu je
pas rentrer dans la caricature que vous
avez i bien porté mon cher collègue
parce que le sujet grave moi j'habite
une île où il y a 30% chur monsieur 30
60 % des jeunes de moins de 25 ans sont
au chômage 60 dans l'Hexagone 25 et
partir de 10% ici vous lancez des
SOS les signaux d'alarme raisonnent de
partout j'ai pas le temps de rigoler
j'ai pas envie de rire et vousz pas
faire rire monsieur parce que j'ai
attendu les prédécesseurs les
gouvernement précédent et dans mon île
quand il venait nous rendre visite nos
ministres il me disait assistana
assistana assistana je ne peux plus
entendre cela monsieur je suis chef
d'entreprise et ma conviction c'est
qu'on ne pourra jamais développer
l'emploi si on ne fait pas marcher et
l'économie marchand économie de
référence économie maîtresse et l'autre
jambre de cette économie qui est
l'économie sociale et
solidaire je suis très respectueux mon
collègue mais j'ai entendre c'est beau
que vous sortez en rigolant ça me fait
pleurer et je vais vous dire une chose
mes amis faisons cette petite expérience
madame la ministre je suis pas concerné
et pourtant je viens de vous dire les
drames que vit mon territoire la Réunion
j'ose espérer que vous retiendrez un un
territoire ultramarin et je rêve que ce
soit le mien je dis simplement mes
collègues et c'est Monsieur van
leurenberg que j'aimerais convaincre
monsieur chassing que j'aimerais
convaincre je vous ai entendu en
commission euh l'esprit
ouvert tentons
l'expérience l'économie marchande c'est
l'économie de références nous avons
aujourd'hui depuis
2014 une loi revisiter sur les
associations sur les coopérativ une loi
qui a considérablement fait avancer les
choses c'est nous qui l'avons fait mais
quelque part je vous compte
dedans j'en prends pas ombrage certains
d'entre vous y étaient
je dis simplement que faisons de cette
économie d'accueil l'économie
d'expérience de cette démarche et
monsieur wenrenberg je vous l'ai dit ce
matin je suis persuadé que cette
économie sociale et solidaire au travers
cette expérimentation ouvrira des champs
qui seront demain autant de passerelles
vers l'économie de référence l'économie
marchand je vous remercie merci la
parole est à Madame
Blandin
chers collègues chacun parle avec son
cœur et la dernière intervention le
prouve et vous avez tous parlé avec vos
convictions mais il reste 2hur on n' pas
encore voté un amendement et vous avez
la force du nombre et d'un côté de
l'autre donc laissz le coupré du vote se
faire avant 1 heure sinon vous jouez la
montre vous évitez de vous prononcer et
la loi passera pas monsieur van
lberg juste un mot madame la Présidente
pour retenir effectivement la demande de
Madame Blandin je dis franchement si
vous croyez à cette loi si vous croyez à
cette expérimentation de grâce réduisez
la durée je ne crois pas aux arguments
qui ont été avancés jusqu'à présent avec
3 ans on a assez de temps mais est-ce
que vous êtes conscient de ça je pense
que vous êtes figé on est dans
l'expérimentation il faut tester on sait
très bien que ça sera imparfait mais
c'est le test donc il faut aller vite
sinon on va être comme l'a dit tout à
l'heure Olivier CIC for justement on va
attendre 2020 avant de commencer
peut-être à péréniser le système mais
les chômeurs n'attendent
pas Madame
brick franchement euh monsieur vanrberg
si c'est on est en séance pour refaire
le débat de la commission qui a été long
et sérieux c'est pas du bon travail
parlementaire moi je crois qu'on est sur
le sous-amendement 64 il s'agit de la
durée et je pense que Monsieur Mouillet
a bien décrit le dispositif qu'il
connaît bien puisqu'il en a un sur son
territoire il faut du temps pour le
mettre en route et je voudrais vous
faire remarquer aussi quelque chose
d'extrêmement important c'est qu'une
c'est une loi qui dans son énoncé
comporte une évaluation c'est
extrêmement important nous n'avons pas
la culture d'évaluation en France et là
c'est une première nous allons évaluer
le travail qui sera fait et madame la
ministre vous a dit que le bilan
commencerait 18 mois avant la date
maximale de 5 ans si vous faites bien
les comptes entre ce que vous a dit
notre collègue le temps de préparation
le temps de mobilisation des acteurs et
le temps où commence le bilan vous avez
quand même une durée très courte pour
faire cette évaluation alors ne nous
faisons pas de mauvais procès je crois
que si on veut une loi
d'expérimentation une loi où il y a une
évaluation qui plusé grâce à la
rapporteur et aux remarques qui ont été
faites par les associations porteuses
ATD carmonde et par le Conseil
économique et social ce sera fait par un
organisme indépendant donc c'est une
première cette loi c'est vraiment une
loi d'innovation social et c'est ça que
nous voulons voter alors elle ne va pas
se substituer à bien d'autres
mécanismes qui du reste vont être
annoncés le 18 par le Président de la
République mais qui existe déjà et je
reparlerai tout à l'heure pour répondre
à vos argumentations sur les emplois
marchands mais là il s'agit de la
durée merci alors je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement 64
le sous-amendement pardon 64 qui a reçu
un avis favorable de la commission
défavorable du gouvernement qui est donc
pour
3 qui est
contre qui
s'abstient l'amendement n'est pas adopté
un amendement 60 qui a a reçu deux avis
défavoraable commission et gouvernement
qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté le sous-amendement 61
avis défavorable de la commission
favorable du
gouvernement qui est
pour qui est
contre
séri 2 3
alors euh comme le résultat est serré
pour ne pas être sûr de ne pas nous
tromper nous allons faire assis debout
donc qui est pour
euh
oui 1 2 3 4 5
6 1 19
bien qui est
contre 25 non
27 l'amendement est
adopté le sous-amendement vraiment
excusez-moi et alors maintenant vote de
l'amendement 8
euh qui a reçu deux avis favorables qui
est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient l'amendement est
adopté le 55 et le 43
tombent nous passons à l'amendement
numéro 9 qui est présenté
par Monsieur Jean sanetas vous avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente donc
sur l'amendement 9 rectifié cet
amendement procède à des coordinations
et clarification juridique qui vient
corriger un oubli relatif aux EPCI qui
devront financer l'expérimentation
évidemment sur une base du
volontariat alors avis de la commission
madame la rapporteur la commission a
donné un avis favorable merci avis du
gouvernement favorable favorable je le
mets au voix avec deux avis favorables
qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté amendement 2 rectifié bis
monsieur mouer le présente
oui je je le présente simplement pour
réinsister de nouveau sur la nécessité
d'un concours volontaire au niveau
financier de la part des collectivités
ça a été beaucoup dit au moment des
inention à la discussion générale mais
je crois que c'est vraiment le point
fondamental en tout cas pour pour notre
groupe politique sur cette clarté donc
ça a été je je connais déjà les les avis
donc je serais amené à retirer cet
amendement mais j'entends j'entends
quand même l'intervention de madame la
ministre pour bien de le repréciser
alors habit de la
commission alors la Commission a
considéré que la la demande de Monsieur
Mouillet était était satisfaite et a
donné un avis défavorable s'il
n'acceptait pas le retrait bien avis du
gouvernement madame la
ministre écoutez la question du
financement a beaucoup été abordée tout
à l'heure moi je l'ai dit devant vous
l'état consentira un effort financier
exceptionnel pour la première année pour
mieux accompagner le lancement on a
parlé d'amorça justement cette
expérimentation et la et sa mise en
œuvre je vous confirme que la
participation de l'État s'élèvera à la
hauteur équivalente d'un CIE je crois
que c'est un signal fort et le
gouvernement s'y engage devant vous le
fait qu'on mette que les collectivités
locales soient volontaires bien sûr
qu'on ira chercher aussi la
participation d'organismes public
d'organismes privés mais le caractère
volontaire de la participation des
collectivités locales montre que en
effet l'amendement est aujourd'hui
satisfait et donc je vous invite à le
retirer monsieur Mouillet vous le
retirez parfait nous passons à
l'amendement suivant le 10 rectifié
Monsieur Jean
sanetas présidente madame ministre donc
cet amendement procède aussi là des
coordinations et clarification juridique
qui viennent de nouveau corriger un
oubli relatif aux zepci merci avis de la
commission madame la alors pour pour
compléter un peu ce que vient de dire
Monsieur Jean sanetta c'est un un
amendement important puisqu'ilopère la
distinction entre le
rapport portant sur le bilan de
l'expérimentation et celui de de son
évaluation et la commission a donné un
avis favorable à cet amendement avis du
gouvernement favorable favorable je mets
au voix avec deux avis favorables qui
est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté amendement suivant 40
rectifié terme monsieur gabouti
oui cet amendement avait s'inséré dans
le dispositif de réduction de de 5 à 3
ans mais effectivement comme on est sur
un petit échantillon avec petites de
petites ambitions et que par contre on
est sur des délais relativement longs
restons sur les délais longs 18 mois 5
ans donc l'amendement n'a plus d'intérêt
je le retire vous le retirez merci
beaucoup alors nous poursuivons avec un
amendement et un sous-amendement qui
font l'objet d'une discussion commune
Monsieur Jean sanetas pour l'amendement
11 rectifier bis
oui cet amendement est sans doute comme
l'aindiqué le rapporteur madame la
rapporteur ce matin en commission le
plus important parmi ceux que nous
examinons ce soir en effet il confie un
comité scientifique indépendant
spécifique le soin de réaliser
l'évaluation de l'expérimentation le
fond étant seulement chargé de réaliser
son bilan comptable et financier cet
amendement s'inspire du mécanisme mise
en place pour l'évaluation de la
garantie jeune et devrait permettre un
débat serein sur l'opportunité de
généraliser ou non
l'expérimentation
merci le sous-amendement 62 est présenté
par Madame David oui merci madame la
Présidente nous sommes en plein accord
avec ce que vient de présenter notre
collègue et nous souhaitons euh que
cette expérimentation qui se fera donc
par un comité scientifique indépendant
puisse également évaluer les formations
suivies par les personnes engagées dans
ce processus puisqueen effet une partie
de la réussite de ce
dispositif tournera aussi autour des
formations qui leur seront accorder et
il nous semble donc important que dans
ce bilan de l'expérimentation les
formations suivies soit comprise dans le
périmètre de l'expérimentation c'est le
sens de ce de ce sous-amendement que
nous faisons à cet amendement merci avis
de la commission sur amendement et
sous-amendement alors la Commission
avait émis un avis de sagesse sur le
sous-amendement 62 qui est en fait la la
traduction du de de l'amendement qui
avait été examiné ce matin et un avis
favorable à l'amendement numéro 11 merci
avis du gouvernement madame la ministre
avis favorable sur les deux amendements
favorable sur les deux alors
nous on va mettre au voix le
sous-amendement 62 avis sagesse de la
commission favorable du gouvernement qui
est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté et
donc vote sur l'amendement 11 avec deux
avis favorables qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est donc adopté je mets au voie donc
l'article
1er qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté
alors nous passons à l'article 2 avec
l'amendement 12 rectifié Monsieur Jean
sanetas merci donc cet amendement
clarifie la liste des bénéficiaires de
l'expérimentation tout en l'élargissant
au demandeurs d'emploi qui ont
démissionné de leurs anciens postes et
ceux qui ont conclu une rupture
conventionnelle nous avons été en effet
nombreux sur tous les bancs de notre
haute assemblée à nous interroger sur le
cas de ces personnes qui au moins
formellement ne sont pas
involontairement privé d'emploi elles
peuvent néanmoins être inscrites à Pôle
emploi depuis plus d'un an et répondre
au critère essentiel qui est celui du
chômage de longue durée merci
alors avis de la commission sur cet
amendement l'avis est favorable
favorable madame la ministre favorable
favorable donc je ah ah madame David une
prise de parole
oui très rapidement juste pour dire que
nous sommes en plein accord avec cet
amendement et que en en commission c'est
ce que je disais tout à l'heure à la
tribune dans la discussion nous avons
retiré un amendement qui a poursuivait
le même but qui n'était pas rédigé de la
même manière mais poursuivait le même
but donc nous avons retiré notre
amendement et bien évidemment nous
voterons en faveur de celui présenté par
nos collègues du groupe socialiste merci
beaucoup donc je le mets au voix deux
avis favorables qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement est adopté et donc les deux
amendements suivants
tombe et
donc et donc l'article est
ainsi
reécrit alors nous en sommes à l'article
3 où là nous avons 7 amendements et un
sous-amendement qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le prer le 13
rectifiis monsieur
jeanetas
pardon nous sommes à l'article 3 avec le
premier
amendement
qu'on j'ai pas
branché cet amendement apporte des
améliorations rédactionnelles et de
coordination qui permettra de distinguer
clairement les territoires retenus pour
l'expérimentation des autres
collectivités notamment le département
ou la région en écho aux interrogations
de la commission ce matin et de la
nouvelle intervention de notre collègue
Philippe Mouillet tout à l'heure je
voudrais ajouter que pour nous le
département et la région auront toute
capacité à participer à
l'expérimentation notamment par les
actions d'accompagnement et de formation
pour autant il est clair que
l'initiative telle qu'elle existe déjà
aujourd'hui dans plusieurs territoire
part du terrain des constats faits sur
celui-ci et de l'implication de tous les
partenaires locaux l'amendement propose
également de renforcer le volet
accompagnement des salariés de
l'entreprise conventionnée comme l'ont
souligné l'agence nouvelle des
Solidarités actives dans son étude de
faisabilité ainsi que le Conseil
économique et social et environnemental
dans son avis merci le sous-amendement
63 non c'est monsieur vatrin qui le
défend oui nous souhaitons ici
sousamender l'amendement 13 rectifié
nous demandons d'inclure à l'alinéa 25
après les mots et de déterminer les
modalités d'accompagnement les mots
notamment en matière de formation
professionnelle professionnelle nous
avions initialement déposé plusieurs
amendements sur le sujet de la formation
professionnelle ne pouvant cependant
être trop directif et suite aux
discussions de ce matin en commission
des affaires sociales nous avons donc
modifié notre rédaction il nous semble
en effet que les ex exigen en terme de
formation attaché à cette
expérimentation doivent être à la
hauteur de la proche l'approche nouvelle
et des ambitions affichées dans ce texte
c'est-à-dire concourir à une insertion
professionnelle durable d de demandeurs
d'emploi de longue durée nous apparaît
aussi très important de citer la
formation au service des demandeurs
d'emploi au moment même où le président
de la République à l'occasion de ses
vœux annoncé l'objectif de former 500000
demandeurs d'emploi contre 150000
actuellement il semble même qu'une de
ces priorité viseraiit les chômeurs de
longue durée dès lors il nous apparaît
normal que les comités locaux qui vont
piloter l'expérimentation prennent bien
en considération la formation
professionnelle dans l'accompagnement
individuel du au demandeurs d'emploi et
la qualité de cette formation si
possible qualifiante à tout le monde
moins certifiante nous vous demandons
pour ces raisons de bien vouloir adopter
ce sous-amendement qui répond à ces
objectifs merci l'amendement 57 monsieur
van lberg le
présente que l'affaire est entendue
c'est encore un amendement qui
concerne les l'économie marchande donc
je le retire tout
simplement très bien le 42 rectifié bis
monsieur gabouti le
présente et oui madame la présidente
madame la ministre chers collègues
simplement en matière de gestion il est
parlé de effectivement de gestion par
une association dont la composition du
conseil d'administration est défin dans
le présent texte euh ce qui n'était pas
nécessairement obligatoire dans la à
mesure où on ne connaît même pas les
statuts de la dite association donc sauf
qu'il est composé d'un conseil
d'administration qui si j'ai bien compté
pourrait compter pourrait avoir entre 50
et 60 membres lorsquon gère un fond et
lorsquon gère une association confier la
gestion à une instance qui compte de 50
à 60 membres je dirais est une est une
inflation qui est d'une plus grande
inefficacité et donc moi je propose une
réduction à 20 membres faisant confiance
au gouvernement puisque la liste
pourrait être fixée par décret ce qui
n'empêche pas d'autres organismes
représentants qualifiés sans voie
délibérative d'être associé aux 10
travaux de l'association et de son
conseil d'administration donc c'est une
je dirais un amendement d'efficacité de
fonctionnement de la structure
gestionnaire du
fond merci l'amendement suivant monsieur
Husson le représente c'est le 5
oui madame madame la Présidente mes
chers collègues simplement il est
proposé enfin quand je dis simplement
c'est c'est un ajout qui a son
importance puisque vous savez que
l'alliance ville emploi est une
association qui est finalement la tête
de réseau des maisons de l'emploi et
déplis tous les cas partout sur leitoire
sur le territoire national où elles
existent et où leur savoir-faire sont
reconnus il apparaît donc parfaitement
cohérent que cette association soit
représenté à chaque fois dans le conseil
d'administration puisqueà la fois ça
rejoint son objet ses compétences son
savoir-faire son
expertise merci l'amendement suivant 52
rectifié madame Jouve
oui cet amendement rejoint le précédent
donc l'article 3 précise notamment
l'émission et la composition du fond
d'expérimentation territoriale contre le
chômage de longue durée ainsi la gest du
fond sera assuré par une association
dirigée par un conseil d'administration
de 32 membres parmi lesquels seront
notamment représenté le Conseil national
des politiques de lutte contre la
pauvreté et d'exclusion sociale le
Conseil supérieur de l'économie sociale
et solidaire pour l'emploi et cetera cet
amendement propose que le conseil
d'administration de l'association
comprenne également un représentant de
l'Alliance ville emploi cette
association regroupe les collectivité
territorial commune établissement
publics de coopération intercommunale
ainsi que leurs outils teroriaux de
développement de l'insertion et de
l'emploi les maisons de l'emploi et les
plans locaux pour l'insertion et
l'emploi son président l'a rappelé c'est
un creusé d'expérien à partager une
vitrine de cette volonté d'initiative
des collectivités territoriales et une
force d'entraînement de tous les élus
locaux pour le développement de
l'insertion de l'emploi aussi sa
présence au sein du conseil
d'administration de l'association qui
met en place cette expérimentation en
faveur de l'emploi au niveau
intercommunal et tout à fait légitime
merci amendement suivant le 7 rectifié
monsieur
Husson voilà alors toujours dans le
cadre de cette
expérimentation je pense qu'il faut
rappeler que partout je viens de le dire
à l'instant où existe un C N de
dispositifs sur les territoires qui
s'occupent d'emploi et d'insertion et
notamment quand ils sont fédérés par les
communes dans des
intercommunalités l'objectif non
seulement c'est de s'appuyer dessus mais
c'est de les rendre compatibles avec les
dispositifs existants qui sont repris
dans l'amendement que ce soit sur les
principe de coordination des politiques
de l'emploi préexistante sur les
territoires mais que ce soit également
de les nouvelles conventions régionales
pluriannuell de coordination de l'emploi
ou bien encore dans le schéma régional
de développement économique d'innovation
et
d'internationalisation c'est-à-dire ce
qui est tout tout à fait conforme à à la
loi nôtre
pardon amendement 48 rectifié madame
Jouve
ou madame
Malherbe pardon c'est
comm effectivement c'est important dans
ce cadre là que les actions du comité
soient en cohérence avec tout ce qui
existe déjà et qui sont portés par les
acteurs locaux et on estimait
effectivement que c'est c'est mieux en
l'écrivant he dans le cadre de l'alinéa
26 sur le comuné local qui établi un
programme d'action approuvé par le fond
et on souhaitait pouvoir ajouter en
cohérence bien évidemment avec les
actions des acteurs territoriaux pour
l'emploi donc effectivement la
discussion qui a eu lieu ce matin en
commission des affaires sociales
énoncait que il était à priori satisfait
mais je voudrais les précisions qui
m'assure que ce cet amendement est est
bien satisfait pour pouvoir le re tirer
parce que sinon il est pour nous
fondamental que cette cohérence existe
avec l'ensemble des acteurs territoriaux
même si ça paraît être une évidence
merci beaucoup merci alors avis de la
commission sur cette série amendement et
sous-amendement alors sur la sur la
totalité de des amendements en
discussion commune donc sur le
sous-amendement 63
euh la la Commission a estimé ce matin
que ne voyez pas la nécessité de
préciser la notion d'accompagnement qui
est le premier euh la première partie de
de l'amendement et qui comprend
évidemment les actions de formation mais
qui ne se ne s'y réduit pas et l'avis
est plutôt
défavorable sur l'amendement numéro 13
euh obligation pour le comité local de
prévoir les actions d'accompagnement des
bénéficiaires de l'expérimentation en
lien avec le service public de l'emploi
c'est un avis
favorable sur l'amendement 42 de
Monsieur
gabouti moi j'avais indiqué en
commission qu'il me semblait difficile
de revenir sur un accord qui avait été
trouvé à l'Assemblée nationale sur la
composition du conseil d'administration
mais néanmoins la Commission avait donné
un avis favorable à cet
amendement sur le numéro 5 concernant
l'attribution d'un siège à à
l'association alliance ville emploi donc
sur les amendements 27 et 52 qui ont le
même le même objet
euh nous avions
eu
une une discussion et et et quelques
hésitations même si d'un côté il est un
peu difficile de d'être favorable à une
restriction à à un conseil
d'administration de 20 membres et et
d'un autre côté à l'étendre un nouveau à
une nouvelle
participation la position de la de la
commission était la demande de retrait
sinon un avis défavorable sur les trois
amendements euh le
502 donc c'est un avis défavorable 7
rectifié obligation pour les comités
locaux de comprendre les maision de
l'emploi et structure
P c'est un c'est également une position
de retrait ou un avis défavorable et le
48 obligation d'établir un programme
d'action en cohérence avec
l'action des acteurs territoriaux pour
l'emploi c'est un amendement qui nous
paraît largement satisfait dont nous
avons demandé le retrait sinon un avis
défavorable merci alors madame la
ministre avis de
gouvernement alors s'agissant de l'amend
ement numéro 13 c'est un avis favorable
s'agissant euh de
l'amendement
excusez-moi du sous-amendement pardon
numéro 63 de Madame David c'est un avis
défavorable s'agissant du numéro 42
c'est un avis défavorable sur le numéro
57 et 52
écoutez notamment la présence de la la
représentation de alliance ville emploi
au conseil d'administration du fond
écoutez moi j'ai un avis sagesse je je
vois que par exemple dans l'expérience
qui est en train de se mettre en œuvre à
molléon c'est la maison de la MDE qui
s'en occupe de développement de l'emploi
voilà il peut y avoir un intérêt qui
soit au sein du conseil d'administration
du fond donc véritablement je laisse
votre assemblée vous prononcer
s'agissant de l'amendement
visant de l'amendement numéro 7
euh c'est un avis défavorable parce que
si nous commençons à citer l'ensemble
des membres des comités locaux on en
oublie forcément par exemple le Cap
emploi en direction des personnes
handicapées il y en a énormément sur le
territoire et je crois que cette la
réussite de cette expérimentation
partira justement de la capacité des
territoires à eux-mêmes concevoir leurs
comités locaux selon la dynamique de ce
territoire bien évidemment il y aura
tous les acteurs de l'emploi enfin je ne
doute pas comment ça peut être entre
autrement mais c'est vrai que nous
commençons à en mettre quelques-uns on
en oubliera toujours donc je préfère que
ça parle directement des
territoires merci alors je vais nous
allons reprendre l'examen je vais
commencer par mettre au voix le
sous-amendement
63 qui a reçu deux avis défavorables qui
est
pour qui est
contre
qui s'abstient il n'est pas adopté
amendement 13 rectifier bis deux avis
favorable qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est
adopté alors le 42
tombe le 7
également donc nous prenons l'examen du
5 pour lequel la Commission a demandé un
retrait et le gouvernement sagesse donc
j'interroge monsieur
USON vous le maintenez donc je vais le
mettre au voix qui est pour ah Monsieur
Mouillet vous souhaitez intervenir oui
je madame la Présidente juste une
intervention on regarde les discussions
de ce matin on a beaucoup abordé ce
sujet là sur la l'application des des
maisons d'emploi et et finalement votre
intervention ministre nous donne un bon
compromis finalement c'est dire la
reconnaître à un certain niveau mais pas
forcément dans la totalité de de la de
la démarche donc j'aurais moi plutôt un
sentiment favorable aujourd'hui sur cet
amendement même si ce matin les choses
étaient beaucoup plus mitigées mais les
débats servent aussi à évoluer dans nos
propos bien alors je vais le mettre au
voix qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est
adopté je pense même vote pour le
52 et
enfin le
pardon excusez-moi c'est celui où on n
pas eu l'intervention de Madame le
Ministre madame la ministre pardon voilà
vous attendiez une réponse pour
éventuellement le retirer c'était
ça alors madame la ministre sur le 48
rectifié
oui bien
évidemment le projet territorial
déterminera la composition et les
modalités d'organisation et de
fonctionnement du comité local en en
fonction notamment des acteurs
localement présents comme je l'ai dit je
suis pas pour une liste exhaustive parce
qu'on oublie toujours forcément et donc
je pense que vous pouvez retirer votre
amendement parce que il est Satis
madame
Malerbe bon bien que ce soit pas précis
je retire l'amendement vous le retirez
merci alors nous poursuivons
l'amendement 35 madame CEN
oui merci madame la Présidente nous
souhaiterions préciser les critères les
fixés en insérant les mots économiques
sociauxenvironnementaux et garantissant
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
c'est vrai que la discussion que nous
avons eu en commission ont introduit le
fait qu'à partir du moment où on nomme
les critères on risque d'en oublier mais
je veux profiter de ce moment pour
attirer votre attention madame la
ministre sur le souci que nous avons
concernant effectivement le fait que ce
dispositif profite à égalité aux femmes
et aux hommes puisque nous avons vu que
pour le chômage de de longue durée tout
un temps effectivement c'était les
femmes qui pâtissaient de ce chômage à
longue durée aujourd'hui les courbes se
se rejoignent il y a plus de chômeurs
longue durée homme mais néanmoins
justement nous avons également euh un un
phénomène qui fait que il y a un
sous-emploi caché des femmes puisque il
y a un temps partiel qui est très
important chez les femmes donc nous
souhaiterions que le
dispositif profite
autant donc aux femmes qu'aux hommes
c'est une intervention que j'aurais pu
faire à l'amendement numéro 2 mais comme
il a été réécrit totalement et bien
finalement notre amendement est tombé
donc c'est vrai que je profite de cet
incise pour défendre à la fois les
critères que nous voulons voir
apparaître et insister un peu lourdement
sur cette notion qui est importante
puisque c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui
malheureusement l'égalité entre les
femmes et les hommes n'est pas réelle au
niveau de l'insertion professionnelle et
notamment au niveau de la précarité et
du chômage donc voilà pourquoi je
réinsiste sur cet élément merci alors
avis de la commission sur cette alors la
commission bien que partageant le souci
de de Madame Cohen de garantir l'égalité
entre les hommes et les femmes a estimé
que cette liste limitative risquait de
d'être un obstacle parce que elle risque
d'être incomplète et la commission donc
a demandé le retrait de de cet
amendement ou sinon un avis
défavorable gouvernement madame la
ministre oui avis défavorable également
même si je serais particulièrement
vigilante à ce à ces critères mais on
peut pas mettre une liste ça sera
intégré dans le décret qui définira
justement le cahier des charges dans le
cadre de ces expérimentations et bien
sûr la ttention portée sur les femmes
sera bien sûr important madame Kouen bon
alors dans dans ce contexte
effectivement on accepte de retirer
notre amendement mais j'insiste vraiment
sur cette égalité d'accès à ce
dispositif entre les femmes et les
hommes et donc j'entends ce que mes
collègues disent mais je je je souhaite
absolument que ça soit porté dans la
discussion voilà vous re nous le
retirons merci beaucoup et donc nous
allons passer au vote sur l'article 3
qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté article additionnel après
l'article 3 deux amendements
identiques le premier monsieur hon le
présente oui dans la droite ligne des
des amendements défendus précédemment je
pense que là encore il faut tenir compte
des dispositifs existants sur les
territoires puisque ça a été dit depuis
le début de ce
débat les expériences doivent venir du
territoire là où on est bien organisé ou
en tous les cas à travers à nouveau les
PL ou les maisons de l'emploi ben il
apparaît
naturel que ces acteurs dont l'expertise
est essentiel et reconnu participe à
cette à ces expérimentations voilà
l'objet de cet
amendement merci l'amendement suivant
madame Jouve le 53
oui combien de dire monsieur hon cet
amendement vise à associer lorsqu'ils
existent dans les territoires
d'expérimentation les maisons l'emploi
et les plans locaux pour l'insertion et
l'emploi ce sont des outils d'animation
d'innovation et de mise en œuvre des
politiques de l'emploi au niveau local
en coordonnant les actions des
différents acteurs de leur territoire
ils s'inscrivent dans la stratégie
territoriale pour l'insertion et
l'emploi à ce titre il serait tout à
fait légitime de s'appuyer sur ces
acteurs existants qui apporteraient une
expertise essentielle au succès de cette
expérimentation merci avis de la
commission sur ces deux
amendements alors pour les les même avis
pour les les deux amendements euh la
Commission a demandé le le retrait ou
sinon un avis défavorable avis du
gouvernement pour ma part c'est un avis
défavorable je crois que l'enjeu de
cette expérimentation c'est justement de
partir des collectivités et je crois que
c'est dans le cadre de de leur
candidature qu'ils doivent exprimer je
nai je ne souhaite pas à ce stade
euh orienter le pilotage systématique de
ces expérimentations par les les MDE sur
les territoires ou les plis je crois que
ça appartient vraiment en décision à
tous les acteurs locaux et la
collectivité de décider qui doit piloter
on nous reproche bien souvent dans le
champ du Travail de l'Emploi de mettre
en place d'avoir un problème de
lisibilité des dispositifs de mettre en
place bien souvent des choses un peu
trop corseté sur le plan national euh je
le dis d'autant plus que je viens
d'admettre auprès des préfets la
fourgibilité entre les aides au postes
dans l'insertion et les contrats
d'insertion donc on voit bien qu'il y a
une demande qui vient plutôt des
territoires pour qu' ne régidifie pas
trop donc voilà c'est un avis
défavorable parce que je pense qu'il
faut vraiment partir des territoires et
des volontés des
collectivités alors Monsieur Husson euh
madame jou maintenez-vous ces
amendements monsieur Husson alors une
explication madame la ministre bien sûr
que je le maintiens puisque j'ai
l'objectif n'est pas de rendre
obligatoire
mais j'en profite madame la ministre
pour vous pour saluer en tous les cas le
revirement de la position du
gouvernement moi je me je me suis pas
s'exprimer jusqu'à maintenant puisque
concernant le même sujet il y a un an et
demi on nous expliqué que finalement les
maisons de l'emploi peut-être c'était
bien mais comme il y avait une disparité
territoriale B finalement on laissait
les les collectivité locale quand bien
même elle s'implique quand bien même
elle participe au financement de ces
dispositifs plutôt livré elle-même donc
je veux saluer l'engagement sous votre
responsabilité c'est un ministère qui
est bien
compliqué j'en conviens à exercer les
résultats ça été dit par d'autres sont
compliqués mais quand vous vous
mobilisez au côté des collectivités
locales je crois qu'il faut d'abord
penser à cell et ceux qui n'ont pas de
travail et depuis longtemps et là encore
reconnaître la capacité d'expertise
quand les acteurs locaux sur un
territoire se sont en ensemble mis
d'accord pour ce sujet et je veux enfin
vous rappeler madame la ministre puisque
vous y êtes déjà venu quand meurtosel
dans mon département il y a trois
maisons de l'emploi où les trois sur des
territoires différents urbains ou moins
urbains mènent des action de
coordination au service des populations
les plus en difficulté les plus
éloignées de l'emploi c'est la raison
pour laquelle vous avez compris que ma
comattivité ma dédétermination sont
intactes si même avis madame J bien
alors je vais mettre au voix cet
amendement 6 rectifié qui a donc reçu
deux avis
défavorable qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est donc pas
adopté et me sort pour le suivant alors
nous passons à l'article
4 avec deux amendements qui font l'objet
d'une discussion commune le premier le
58 rectifié monsieur
vanlerberg retiré et le suivant monsieur
jeananetas c'est le 14
rectifié c'est un am coordination
bien avis de la commission favorable du
Gouvernement favorable je le mets au
voix qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté amendement suivant 36
rectifié bis madame David
oui merci madame la Présidente cet
amendement est typiquement issu des
travaux que nous avons réalisé ce matin
en commission puisqueen effet il se
substitue à deux amendements précédent
que nous avions déposé hein qui
demandait à préciser que le salarié ou
tout au moins le salaire soit à hauteur
de la grille en en cours dans
l'entreprise qui serait donc
conventionné avec le fond pour employer
ses salariés et un second qui disait que
le temps de travail ne pouvait pas
déroger aux 24 heur qui sont le temps
légal aujourd'hui en vigueur mais avec
la discussion que nous avons eu ce matin
et à confirmation par Madame la
rapporteur que ce dispositif rentrait
bien dans le droit commun du travail il
nous a semblé que plutôt que d'inscrire
dans la loi la notion du SMIG qui du
coup
induirait que on n'est pas dans le droit
commun puisque si on est dans le droit
commun il n'est pas utile de rajouter
dans ce texte que le salaire sera au
minimum au SMIG c'est le droit commun
donc pas besoin de le préciser de fait
il nous semblait qu'on pouvait modifier
la fin de cet article 4 et supprimer la
partie qui par parle justement du SMIG
par une une une phrase qui dirait
conformément au droit du travail ce qui
permet d'assurer
franchement le le le fait que ce
dispositif est bien dans le droit commun
du travail voilà donc ça c'est vraiment
grâce au travail de la commission ce
matin qui nous a permis du coup de de de
transformer ces deux amendements en un
seul et vraiment madame la ministre
madame la rapporteur c'est je pense mal
mal venu d'inscrire dans le texte la
notion du SMIC si véritablement on est
dans le droit commun du travail donc je
vous propose cette mesure qui nous
permettrait d'être du coup tous
d'accord merci avis de la commission
madame la
rapporteur alors les auteurs de de cet
amendement souhaitent que le droit
commun du travail s'applique au CDI
conclu dans le cadre de
l'expérimentation euh je voudrais leur
dire qu'il soit qu'il soit rassuré euh
ils ont commencé à l'êre par rapport à
la réunion de la commission ce matin ce
sera bien le cas et c'est même là un des
points forts de cette expérimentation
qui iront avec la logique dérogatoire
des contrats aidés je pense que la
ministre ne me contredira pas sur sur ce
point c'est pourquoi sur la base de ces
explications et sur une explication
complémentaire euh qui explique pourquoi
la référence aosmque est est inscrite à
l'article 4 c'est pour vous rappeler
quand même que marrage de de
l'expérimentation dans l'idée de dater
descart monde il était prévu que les
contrats seraient au SMIC et de manière
invariable pendant la la les 50 durées
de de l'expérimentation et que c'est je
crois le Conseil économique et social
qui a indiqué que ça n'était ni
souhaitable ni ni
valable merci avis du gouvernement
madame la ministre je n'ai rien à
ajouter défvorable bien alors je vais
mettre au voix cet amendement à Madame
David
oui je vais retirer cet amendement
puisque madame la rapporteur et madame
la ministre nous affirment que nous
sommes bien dans le droit commun mais il
est vrai que dans l'avis du CESE il
était bien précisé qu'il fallait que ce
contrat respecte le droit du travail et
qu'il ne pouvait être question de
bloquer le salaire osmque pendant la
durée de 5 ans de l'expérimentation donc
il est vrai que dans l'article ça a été
légèrement modifié il est dit que c'est
au minimum auos smig au début du
processus ce qui n'empêche pas son
évolution bon donc nous retirons cet
amendement madame la Présidente merci
alors amendement suivant Monsieur Jean
sanetas pour le 15 rectifi merci madame
la Présidente cet amendement est un
amendement donc d'harmonisation et de
coordination il a pour objet de préciser
que le fond d'expérimentation
interviendra dans le financement de
l'indemnité des salariés licenciés que
si le licenciement résulte d'un arrêt
anticipé de l'expérimentation ou de sa
non reconduction merci avis de la
commission favorable je le mets au voix
qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté deux amendements qui font
l'objet d'une discussion commune le 65
est présenté par le gouvernement madame
la ministre vous avez la
parole alors la proposition de loi dans
la version actuelle prévoit que la
rupture du contrat avant la fin de
l'expérimentation et à l'initiative du
salarié pour exercer un CD d'une durée
de 6 mois un CDI ou une formation
qualifiante ne peut pas priver le
salarié de ses droit à l'assurance
chômage comme c'est le cas pour les
contrats aidés suivant les termes de
l'accord d'application du 14 mai 2014
annexé à la convention d'assurance
chômage si le même régime peut
légitimement s'appliquer au
bénéficiaires de l'expérimentation il
revient aux partenaires sociaux d'en
décider et je leur proposerai bien sûr
de s'emparer de ce sujet en attendant et
pour encourager la recherche d'emploi
sur le marché du travail de façon
sécurisée pour les salariés participant
à l'expérimentation le présent
amendement substitue au cadre de la
démission la possibilité de suspendre le
contrat pour accomprir une période
d'essè pour un CDI ou un CDD d'une durée
au moins égale à 6 mois ou bien un CDD
de moins de 6 mois c'est un point très
important et je prends aussi en compte
vos débats que vous avez eu en
commission et à l'amendement qui a été
défendu par Monsieur gabouti si la
période d'c n'est pas concluante par
exemple les salariés pourront si besoin
réintégrer leur entreprise d'accueil et
poursuivre leur parcours professionnel
enfin la nouvelle rédaction ne mentionne
plus les actions de formation
qualifiante car le code du travail
permet déjà d'articuler période de
travail et action de
formation
merci Monsieur gabouti pour l'amendement
oui même si nos amendements précédents
n'avaient pas été pris en
compte par par la ministre et un peu
malmené par la gauche et la
droite je je vous remercie d'avoir
retenu notre réflexion sur celui-ci et
effectivement le texte que vous proposez
permet de contourner certaines
difficultés notamment vis-à-vis de de
l'Unédic dans la mesure où il y avait
une
modification du dispositif et que le but
est bien de faciliter d'encourager la
recherche d'emploi sur le marché du
travail de droit commun je dirais par
les personnes qui serait rentré dans le
dispositif d'expérimentation donc je
retire mon amendement et je j'apporte on
apporte notre soutien à celui du
gouvernement alors avis de la commission
sur l'amendement du Gouvernement dans la
mesure où où la Commission avait
souhaité avoir l'avis du Gouvernement
sur l'amendement de Monsieur gabouti il
me semble que l'amendement que vient de
nous présenter le gouvernement est une
réponse ce qui peut convenir à à la
commission donc donn un avis favorable
très bien donc je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement du Gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté je mets au voix
l'article 4 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté nous
passons à l'article 5 et donc nous avons
l'amendement 25 rectifié Monsieur Jean
sanetas de coordination avis de la
commission favorable du Gouvernement
favorable je le mets au voix qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté le suivant monsieur
jeananetas le 16 rectifié madame la
Présidente c'est un amendement
d'harmonisation et de précision
rédactionnel qui vient notamment
confirmer le fait que la contribution
financière des collectivités au
financement de l'expériment ation ira
bien au projets situés sur leur
territoire respectif merci avis de la
commission favorable du Gouvernement
favorable je le mets au voix qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté le suivant toujours Monsieur
Jean
sanetas 17
rectifie cet amendement précise que le
fond signera bien une convention avec
chacun des organismes publics et privés
participant à l'expérimentation et non
une convention globale avis de la
commission favorable favorable du
Gouvernement je le mets au voix qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté l'amendement suivant 18
rectifié toujours Monsieur Jean sanetas
bien cet amendement 18 rectifié vise en
lien avec les amendements numéro 15 et
23 regrouper les dispositions relatives
aux mesures réglementaires d'application
de la proposition de loi au sein de
l'article 7 bis avis de la commission
favorable favorable du Gouvernement je
le mets au voix qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté je
mets au voix l'article 5 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
est adopté après l'article 5
l'amendement
47 rectifié monsieur Chassin
oui vous avez la parole
oui madame la présidente madame la
ministre monsieur le Président madame le
rapporteur chers
collègues si vous voulez dans le cadre
de la mise en place de l'expérimentation
territoriale visant à réduire le
chauvage de longue
durée il y a aussi les entreprises
adaptées qui effectivement sont dans le
secteur marchant mais seront bien sûr
impliqués et donc je je pense que il est
nécessaire aussi que les travailleurs
classés handicapés et bien puissent
avoir leur place dans ces entreprises
adaptées je rappelle qu'actuellement les
dotations par région sont assez basses
et je pense que pour les territoires qui
vont être retenus ce serait bien
que dans les entreprises adaptées les
travailleurs classés handicapés puissent
avoir de postes
puisque effectivement dans les chôeurs
de longue durée il y a aussi ces
travailleurs classés handicapés al voilà
tel est l'objet de mon amendement
augmentation de 15 % dans les
territoires participant à
l'expérimentation alors avis de la
commission madame la
rapporteur alors sur cet amendement la
la la Commission a eu un peu de de mal à
saisir la l'intérêt de de ce de ce qui
lui semble être un peu un un cavalier
par la la demande faite par Monsieur par
Monsieur
Chassin dans la mesure où les
Entreprises Adaptées peuvent
conventionner dans le cadre de de
l'expérimentation c'est quelque chose
qui est prévu et dans le cas où elle ne
conventionne pas nous nous sommes
interrogés sur le lien à faire entre
l'augmentation possible de l'effectif de
référence et la et la contractualisation
donc la Commission a souhaité avoir
l'avis du Gouvernement sur cet
amendement alors avis du gouvernement
merci je partage monsieur Chassin le
fait que cette expérimentation doit
absolument inclure en effet une action
en direction si les demandeurs d'emploi
de longue durée sont des personnes en
situation d' handicap il est normal bien
évidemment qu'elle puisse en bénéficier
mais je crois pas que ce soit par ce
biais de cette augmentation qu'on
augmentera la part sur les entreprises
adaptées pour moi la situation en effet
des personnes en situation de handicap
dans leur accès au marché du travail et
euh intolérable dans notre pays je P je
pense qu'on peut le dire nous avons en
effet quand on met en place de plus en
plus par exemple dans les cadres des
contrats aidés dans le secteur non
marchand nous sommes passés de 10 % à 15
% de personnes en situation de handicap
parce que nous voyons bien que nous
avons particulièrement de difficultés
justement pour qu'il puisse accéder au
marché du travail c'est pour ça que dans
le budget que j'ai porté devant vous
pour l'année 2016 j'ai augmenté de 500
aides aux postes dans les entreprises
adaptées et nous allons continuer à
faire mais je crois qu'il faut
pas trop figer les choses par rapport à
cela les personnesation handicap
pourront bénéficier de l'expérimentation
bien évidemment mais ça n'a pas
véritablement de lien avec les aides
qu'on peut apporter par ailleurs aux
Entreprises
Adaptées
merci donc je vais mettre au voix à
Monsieur
Chassin vous retirez votre amendement
merci beaucoup alors nous passons au
vote de l'article
6 il est supprimé pardon l'article 7
nous avons
l'amendement 19 et c'est Monsieur Jean
sanetas c'est un amendement madame la
Présidente d'harmonisation
rédactionnelle très bien avis de la
commission
gouvernement avis du
gouvernement favorable je mets au voix
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est adopté
amendement suivant le 20 rectifié
Monsieur Jean sanetas bien cet
amendement porte sur le licenciement des
salariés des entreprises conventionnées
il limite explicitement la
reconnaissance par la loi d'un
licenciement individuel pour motif
économique au seul cas où ce
licenciement serait consécutif à l'arrêt
prématurer du versement à l'entreprise
de l'aide financière par le fond dans ce
seul cas le fond financera une partie de
l'emnité de lic des salariés concernés
avis de la commission faorable favorable
du Gouvernement favorable je le mets au
voix qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il est
adopté je mets au voix l'article 7 qui
est pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
il est adopté article 7 bis amendement
21 rectifié Monsieur Jean
sanetas bien comme nous l'avons adopté à
l'article 1er cet amendement
d'harmonisation précise que l'évaluation
de l'expérimentation ne doit pas être
assuré par le fond lui-même mais par un
comité indépendant avis de la commission
favorable du Gouvernement je mets au
voix qui est pour qui est contre qui
s'abstient il est adopté le suivant
toujours Monsieur Jean sanetas Le
22ésid avis de la du gouvernement je au
voix qui est pour
qui est contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté monsieur jeanas pour le 23
rectifier l'amendement 23 rectifié c'est
un simple amendement de coordination
mais qui nous conduit à rappeler le
principe même du fonctionnement de
l'expérimentation l'objectif de cette
expérimentation est qu'audelà de la
phase d'amorçage l'activité de
l'entreprise ainsi créée devienne
progressivement solvable ce but devrait
être atteint puisque les activités de
l'entreprise seront déterminé à part de
l'évaluation de besoins identifiés sur
le terrain mais non pris en charge par
le secteur marchand au fur et à mesure
que l'activité se développe et génère un
profil l'entreprise peut prendre en
charge directement la rémunération des
salariés l'équilibre se met en place et
le soutien financier du fond peut-être
dégressif il est donc simplement
nécessaire de le préciser dans le décret
d'application de la loi tout comme il
est nécessaire de préciser dans ce texte
les modalités de la participation de
l'État c'est la de la technique
juridique qui ne présage en rien du
maintien du montant global de la
participation de l'État en rapport avec
l'extension du dispositif avis de la
commission sur cet amendement alors cet
amendement a donné lieu ce matin en
commission à un long débat qui a été
nourri je crois par des incompréhensions
sur sa portée réelle je tiens à rappeler
qu'il n'ajoute rien à la PPL telle
qu'elle a été adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale et qu'il s'agit uniquement
d'un amendement de logistique qui vise à
réintroduire à l'article 7 bis qui
concerne les modalités réglementaires
d'application de la proposition de loi
les dispositions portant sur ce sujet
qui ont été retirées des articles 4 et 5
par les amendements qui ont été qui
viennent d'être votés les amendements 15
et 18 euh je peux vous rappeler son
objet il prévoit que le décret
d'application de la loi devra prévoir
les conditions de l'éventuelle
dégressivité dans le temps non pas de la
participation de l'État ce qui était le
le sens de la du vote défavorable en
commission ce matin mais du montant de
l'aide versée par le fond à chacune des
entreprises conventionnées pourquoi
envisager cette décrressivité parce que
le but de cette expérimentation est bien
de rendre solvables des activités
nouvelles il est donc tout à fait
possible d'envisager qu'au bout d'un ou
2 ans leur rentabilité s'améliore et
dans ces conditions le fond n'aurait
plus à compenser un différentiel aussi
important qu'à l'origine entre le coût
du salarié pour l'entreprise et le
bénéfice qui lui permet réalisé je
précise qu'il s'agit là d'un point
demandé par les associations porteuses
de de l'expérimentation
et je vous rappelle enfin qu'il est
prévu que le décret fixe les modalités
de participation de l'État au fond ces
mots figurés à l'algéa 4 de l'article 5
il n'est pas question ici de prévoir de
manière détournée un éventuel
désengagement anticipé de l'État qui
abandonnerait les collectivités
volontaes à leur propre sort je crois
que madame la ministre a donné toutes
les précisions nécessaires lors de
l'examen de ces de ces amendements et de
l'article 5 donc je je vous proposerai
bien que l'avis de la commission est été
défavorable de
reconsidérer cet avis à l'ône des
explications que je viens de vous
donner avis du gouvernement madame la
ministre favorable favorable monsieur
Mouillet madame la Présidente j'entends
bien tous les tous les arguments qui ont
été apportés madame la par Madame la
rapporteur simplement quand même vous
venez de de commencer votre explication
pour n n expliquer que ça n rajouter
rien à la PPL donc c c cet amendement ne
rajoute rien à la ppll mais en même
temps on nous indique depuis le début de
nos discussions que on nous rassure
rassure les collectivités sur le
financement et en fin de discussion on
nous explique que la dégressivité de de
l'État va être mis dans le texte de loi
en même temps on nous dit que c'est le
décret qui fixe les modalités donc je
comprends pas pourquoi est-ce qu'on
rajoute cet amendement puisque les
décrets par définition fixent déjà les
règles du jeu voilà donc moi je je suis
toujours considère que c'est un un
mauvais signe et donc si réellement ça
n'apporte rien de pacifique à la PPL je
vois pourquoi c'est mentionné à
l'intérieur je pense réellement que on a
besoin d'être assuré en fin de débat
j'avoue que c'est un c'est un une
éducation qui nous qui nous dérange dans
tous les cas et je moi je confirme
l'avis de la commission de ce matin euh
donc de nouveau avec un sentiment
défavorable sur cet
amendement alors madame
brick non et après madame la ministre
oui oui chers chers collègues moi je
crois que ce qui ce que je comprends y
compris en me remémorant notre
discussion de ce matin c'est que cet
amendement n'apporte pas juridiquement
plus ou moins du reste au texte mais il
l'éclaire et peut-être aurions nous
avoir ce débat en début de séance parce
que certaines nos collègues monsieur
Chassin monsieur van rinberg ont fait
allusion justement au aux emplois
marchands privés et là c'est bien le but
économique de la proposition de loi qui
est une loi d'innovation sociale certes
mais aussi une loi avec une logique
économique c'est-à-dire que nous voulons
créer des emplois
solevables par l'activité économique et
ce matin en commission je veux pas le
refaire maintenant il est trop tard je
vous ai pris l'exemple des déchets qui
étai géré de manière associative il y a
plus de 30 ans et qui maintenant sont
rentrés dans un
process quasi industriel avec des
emplois marchands et souvent privés donc
je crois que c'est ça vraiment la
logique du texte et je voudrais vous en
convaincre pour vous faire revenir sur
votre choix de ce matin ce n'est pas
uniquement une loi d'innovation sociale
c'est une loi qui a une logique
économique créer des emplois solvables
et c'est ça que dit
l'amendement merci Madame
David moi j'entends ce que nous dit
Madame brick pour rassurer monsieur
Mouillet mais comme ce matin en
commission j'avoue pour essayer de
convaincre nos collègues et de nous
convaincre aussi mais j'avoue que arrivé
en fin de discussion où les choses se
sont plutôt bien passées et là on nous
dit les modalités en fonction des
modalités de participation de l'État au
fond alors quelque part j'entends ce que
vous nous dites et qu'il n'y a pas
d'interrogation à voir mais mais quand
même je je trouve que c'est un petit peu
dommage à l'heure où nos collectivités
territoriales sont déjà un petit peu
inquiètes de leurs finances euh de
mettre cette phrase là à ce moment-là on
pourrait simplement dire qui peut être
dég dégressif dans le temps en fonction
de la situation de l'entreprise et puis
à la limite on peut s'arrêter là mais
mais mais parler après des modalités de
financement du fond au fond pardon par
l'État ça me semble un peu malvenu ça
nous empêchera pas de de de continuer de
maintenir notre confiance dans le texte
et et d'apporter un vote positif mais ça
nous interroge un petit peu néanmoins
donc madame la ministre si vous pouviez
comme je vous le demandais dans mon
intervention générale nous rassurer sur
le fait que ce ne seront pas les
collectivités forcément qui seront
amenés à à à financer si toutefois
l'État se
désengageait je pense que ce serait nous
apporter des des des réponses fortes et
ça répondrait aussi en d'une certaine
man manière aux préconisation du CESE
qui lui-même demandait à ce que le
financement soit inscrit dans une loi de
de
finance madame la rapporteur a demandé
la parole vous avez la parole
oui je voudrais vous redonner lecture de
l'article 7
bis pour que vous
voyez en quoi le le complément consiste
l'article 7 bis dans la version donc qui
qui a été adoptée par l'Assemblée
nationale dit un décret en Conseil
d'État définit les modalité
d'application de la présente loi
notamment la méthodologie de
l'évaluation de l'expérimentation par le
fond d'expérimentation territoriale
contre le chômage de longue durée les
modalités de fonctionnement et de
gestion du fond et des comités locaux
mentionnés à l'article 3 les modalités
de passation des conventions conclues
entre le fond et les entreprises
mentionnées à l'article 4 et celle
conclu entre le fond et les ité
territoriale les établissements publics
de coopération intercommunale ou les
groupes de collectivité territoriale
habilité ainsi que les critères retenus
pour fixer le montant de la fraction de
la rémunération prise en charge par le
fond mentionné à l'article 3 et notre
amendement propose simplement d'ajouter
qui peut-être dégressif dans le
temps la le montant de la fraction de la
rémunération prise en charge par le
fond
quel est l'intérêt bah d'être d'être
d'être clair sur sur le fait
qu'effectivement la la participation du
fond peut être amenée à être dégressive
à partir du moment où l'emploi devient
devient rentable simplement
alors est-ce qu'on peut est-ce qu'on
peut envisager de modifier de modifier
cet amendement en supprimant la dernière
partie qui qui semble vous faire
problème particulièrement qui concerne
les modalités de participation de l'État
au fond dans la mesure où où madame la
ministre a été clair sur son sur son
engagement je lui sollicite son avis
alors madame la
ministre je pense que bon c'était
important que vous relisiez l'article 7
bis parce
que moi il me semble que cette
amendement rassemble quelques points qui
ont été précédemment répartis dans les
articles 4 et 5 ce faisant il clarifie
un point qui est très utile euh la
subvention accordée par le fond pourra
être dégressive mais cette dégressivité
n'est pas automatique comme pouvait le
le laisser entendre le la précédente
formulation du texte dans la proposition
de loi donc pour le fond il s'agira de
tenir compte du modèle économique de
l'entreprise conventionné et sa
situation financière voilà euh l'enjeu
de il me semble de cet avant de cet
amendement donc il y a parce que l'enjeu
de ce dispositif c'est que quand même
les activités deviennent pérennne et
qu'elle n'it plus besoin puisqu'on va
essayer de montrer qu'avec l'utilisation
de dépenses Activ nous pouvons justement
mettre en emploi des personnes sur des
sur des activités qui sont viables donc
on voit bien il y avait deux écueils un
de dire que la dégressivité était
automatique donc ne pas prendre le en
compte la capacité justement de laisser
peut-être plus de temps à tel ou telle
activité par rapport à d'autres et il y
avait un autre écueil qui était de dire
il y a pas de dégressivité c'est des
financements de l'État et des autres
partenaires tout au long de
l'expérimentation donc
là il me semble que la formulation telle
qu'elle est apportée rappelle que la
dégressivité elle se fait par rapport à
la situation économique qui sont mis en
œuvre par l'entreprise madame de roche
ou oui merci madame la Présidente je
pense que lorsqu on a abordé ce texte on
l'a fait en effet comme une loi
d'expérimentation et qui n'était pas du
tout question lors de ce texte de sur
légiférer par rapport à ce qui était
sorti de l'Assemblée nationale une des
craintes quand même exprimées par notre
groupe c'était celui euh de la charge
qui pouvait basculer à un moment sur les
collectivités locales et et il faut
reconnaître que la
formulation de l'amendement tel que tel
qu'il est défini de cette modalité de
participation de l'État au fond avec un
côté dégressif on peut avoir un côté
très très inquiétant et et qui ne
rassure pas et les
collectivités et même les entreprises et
dans le cadre de cette expérimentation
et et du texte tel qu'il est sorti de la
de l'Assemblée nationale nous restons
toujours défavoraable à cet
amendement bien alors je vais mettre au
voix cet amendement défavorable avis de
la commission favorable du Gouvernement
alors qui est
pour qui est
contre
16 ah oui
l'amendement n'est pas
adopté je mets au voix l'article 7 B euh
qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient l'article 7 bis
est
adopté même vote pour le 7
TER l'article 8 reste supprimé et nous
arrivons à trois amendements
identique qui porte sur l'intitulé de la
proposition de loi le premier Monsieur
Jean sanetas vous avez la parole merci
madame la présidente madame la ministre
il est bon d'être ambitieux mais il
n'est pas raisonnable d'être
présomptueux il ne serait pas non plus
digne du
législateur de faire croire ou de
laisser croire qu'il a trouvé une
formule magique pour faire disparaître
le chômage de longue durée d'ailleurs
personne ne le croirait nous savons que
là où se trouvent les personnes les plus
en difficulté celles qui doivent
particulièrement bénéficier d'un
accompagnement adapté à leur réinsertion
dans l'activité économique et de
l'emploi c'est une œuvre de longue
haleine qui exige la mobilisation de
tous nous y prenons ici modestement
notre part en permettant à l'initiative
des grandes associations et des
partenaires locaux de se développer
pleinement il est bien évident que ce
texte ne permettra pas de faire
disparaître le chômage de longue durée
nous n'avons pas sur ce point d'illusion
mais nous nous avons l'espoir de
parvenir à le contenir et
progressivement à le réduire et le
résorber cet espoir nous voulons tous
par cette loi le partager avec tous ceux
qui vivent cette situation ou craignent
de la vivre un jour voilà pourquoi nous
proposons un intitulé plus exact de de
la future loi
et
alorsiss
résorber
je de faire disparaître le chômageé il
serait je vois je le vois pas il est
tard
excusez-moi à résorber le chômage de
longue durée voilà raison bien alors
l'amendement 26
rectifié monsieur gabouti
oui c'est c'est le même le même
amendement avec
à peu près les mêmes explications bien
sûr certains auraient préféré qu'on
utilise les termes diminuer réduire mais
dans la mesure où ces termes peuvent
être je dirais accompagnés d'un
pourcentage il pourrait être tourné en
ridicule parce que réduire de 0,5 %
c'est effectivement réduire donc il
n'était pas non plus approprié et le
terme résorbé répond
effectivement à l'objectif ambitieux
même s'il est un petit peu irréaliste
mais c'est une ligne d'horizon
de réduire le plus possible le chômage
de longue durée et en même temps c'est
un terme qui donne une indication sur le
caractère progressif et beaucoup plus
réaliste de cette réduction donc je
pense que c'est quelque chose qui peut
faire consensus madame malerde
oui simplement pour compléter puisqu'il
s'agit effectivement du même amendement
je remercie d'abord madame la rapporteur
d'avoir entendu et et toute la
commission des affaires sociales d'avoir
entendu le cri que j'ai pu pousser avant
l'interruption de Noël et et Nouvel An
sur ce sujet non pas par rapport à nous
qui sommes ici mais par rapport à ceux
qui sont concernés et qui et à qui il ne
faut pas faire croire n'importe quoi
effectivement même si on a besoin et
raison d'être ambitieux sur ce sujet-là
et ça c'était important donc l'idée
effectivement de de vouloir faire
disparaître c'était une volonté
intéressante mais dans la manière de le
dire et on sait que il va y avoir de la
communication autour de cela ENF en tout
cas je l'espère et bien il était
important de ne pas comme je l'ai dit d'
l'heure dans dans la discussion générale
provoquer de la frustration de
l'insatisfaction et donc une fois de
plus du désespoir donc très
sincèrement je je je peux que donner ma
satisfaction de de ces différents
amendements et j'espère très sincèrement
qu'ils seront votés à une grande
majorité voire à l'unanimité même si je
sais que certains préfèrent
effectivement la la notion de réduction
j'y reviens pas ça a été expliqué par
mon collègue juste avant moi merci
alors avis de la commission madame la
rapporteur l'avis de la commission est
favorable pour les trois amendements
avis du
gouvernement sagesse je pense que s'il
revient je comprends tout à fait les
arguments et je crois qu'il revient à
cette assemblée justement de décider le
nom de cette loi et je voudrais puisque
c'est la dernière intervention remercier
la rapporteur pour tout le travail
qu'elle a mené sur cette loi parce que
et vous remercier toutes et tous pour la
tenue de ces débats merci alors je vais
mettre au voix à
Monsieur CAD souhaite prendre la parole
merci madame la
Présidente si la question du chômage de
longue durée n'était pas si dramatique
pour les gens concernés comme ça a été
dit et rappel souvent le débat final sur
le titre prêterait à sourire je réponds
à mon collègue qui inter tout à l'heure
je suis également un
entrepreneur mais je ne me paye pas de
mot je me paye de
résultats comme vous je vis sur une île
il y a pas 30 % de chômage il y a 5 %
taux de chômage il y a d'autres
politiques économiques et d'autres
organisations du travail qui permettent
ces
résultats je vous le dis sans rire c'est
cette efficacité que je veux apporter à
mon pays
merci alors je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement les trois amendements qui
sont
identiques commence 24 26 49 qui est
pour voilà qui est
contre qui s'abstient et bien les
amendements sont
adoptés unanimité je je vais mettre au
voix l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
il y a-t-il des demandes d'explication
de vote monsieur
gabori alors madame BRI après oui madame
la présidente madame le ministre je
serai pas très long très très
brièvement le groupe udi s'était investi
positivement dans l'examen de ce texte
avec la volonté de l'améliorer sans en
trahir ni l'esprit ni les objectifs nous
regrettons cependant que l'échantillon
de 10 territoires nous paraît
effectivement un échantillon trop limité
pour tirer des enseignements pertinents
sur un tel dispositif il nous paraît
également antinomique de refuser une
ouverture au secteur marchand au niveau
de
l'expérimentation qui aurait pu être
d'ailleurs ouverture qui aurait pu être
contingentée alors qu'en cas de
conclusion positive sur la dite
expérimentation celle-ci pourra être
étendue au secteur marchand comment
étendre un secteur marchand à alors
qu'on n' pas fait d'expérience sur le 10
secteur donc je crois qu'il y a une
certaine contradiction dans la démarche
et enfin maintenir une durée
d'expérimentation de 5 ans ne répond pas
à la nécessité de réactivité d'un
dispositif de ce
type donc ce point nous paraissait
essentiel malgré cela la majorité grande
majorité disons de notre groupe
approuvera cont tenu des objectifs
poursuivis et de laisser une chance à ce
type
d'expérimentation vera ce texte mais
avec de tels choix en terme de gestion
et de durée on est sans doute loin de
l'inversion de la courbe du chômage de
longue
durée merci Madame brick oui moi je
voudrais dé laabord remercier à la fois
le travail de la rapporteur et puis
remercier aussi le gouvernement parce
que c'est une proposition de loi
vraiment d'origine parlementaire et le
gouvernement y a apporté sa contrib
c'est je pense une coproduction dont on
ne peut que se féliciter puis je veux
remercier la majorité
sénatorial qui apporte finalement son
soutien elle a compris l'enjeu de la
question et je crois que nos concitoyens
attendent ça de nous c'est-à-dire que
sur des
textes nous arrivions à nous mettre
d'accord pour un objectif commun c'est
ce qu'on on appelle retrouver des
majorités d'idées c'est pas si souvent
et je voudrais pour terminer dire à
Monsieur cadiik oui ce n'est pas normal
que la France a un taux de chômage aussi
fort c'est
clair un grand économiste monsieur
Blanchard qui était encore il n a guerre
le Chief économiste du
FMI nous dit dans un hebdomadaire de la
semaine dernière nous dit que on doit
arriver à 8 % et que normalement avec
une réforme du du marché du travail on
devrait arriver à 5 % et moi j'attends
beaucoup des propositions qui nous
seront faites dans la prochaine loi je
crois qu'on se retrouvera à vos côtés
madame la ministre pour en débattre au
Sénat et que il faut pas forcément
mettre en concurrence de l'innovation
sociale et les logiques purement
économiques fussent-ell macroéconomique
je me rappelle de votre intervention de
ce matin monsieur van rberg mais je
crois qu'il faut les mener de pair et
c'est ce que fait ce texte il fait une
confiance au territoire à
l'expérimentation à l'innovation et il
introduit un cadre très clair pour
l'évaluation je crois que nous avons
fait œuvre utile ensemble cette nuit
merci merci Monsieur mouiller
oui madame la Présidente très rapidement
donc donc je on est relativement
satisfait des des débats de ce soir
rappelons hein l'esprit c'était
d'utiliser l'argent finalement qui était
consommé dans l'aide social pour auprès
des personnes qui sont finalement chez
elles pour leur permettre finalement de
par ce biaislà de bénéficier d'un emploi
de CDI donc on voit bien l'enjeu hein
c'est de finalement avoir une approche
différente de de de de de de chômage de
longue durée donc donner cette capacité
à retourner je dirais dans un
environnement euh de société qui
correspond beaucoup plus aux attentes de
des aspirations mais au-delà de tout ça
je crois que on a été rassuré à la fois
par les débats sur les quelques
interrogations mais je rappelle quand
même que le groupe républicain donc est
favorable à C texte de loi mais de
nouveau le message d' entendu madame
Madame le Ministre que ce n'est qu'un
élément dans le processus et que nous
attendons beaucoup beaucoup des avec
urgence d'ailleurs des différentes
mesures économiques en faveur de
l'emploi c'est une urence générale donc
il faut profiter également de cette
conclusion pour rappeler cet élément
essentiel merci merci Madame
Malherbe vous avez la parole oui pour
essayer de de compléter simplement ce
qui vient d'être dit de part et d'autre
effectivement dans cette loi il y a des
des choses qui méritaient ces ces
expériences limitées à 10 et cetera qui
qu'on avait envie en tout cas de voir
plus importante euh donc je n'en dis pas
plus effectivement à partir moment où on
vote la loi loi parce que c'est une
expérimentation et qu'on va de l'avant
et que les débats ont été riches et moi
aussi je félicite à nouveau Madame Anne
Emer Duma pour la tenue de ces débats
madame la rapporteur parce que ça nous a
permis franchement d'avancer les uns et
les autres et de pouvoir se mettre en
ordre de bataille pour continuer dans
cette démarche là puisqu'on sait qu'on
va avoir à travailler sur des des textes
à venir concernant l'emploi une fois de
plus et j'insiste tout particulièrement
effectivement comme ça a été dit parfois
par certains peut-être moins ce soir sur
les très petites entreprises dans nos
territoires sur les artisans et les un
certain nombre de petits commerçants
dans nos territoires qui sont aussi
fortement touchés et qui ont très
souvent envie d'embaucher parfois leur
premier salarié ou leur deuxème salarié
donc en ordre de marche pour travailler
sur ces sujets-là pour nos
concitoyens la parole à Madame David
merci madame la Présidente pour dire à
mon tour mon plaisir de voir ce texte
adopté pratiquement sur tous les bancs à
l'unanimité sans doute que ce travail ce
vote et le résultat bien sûr je l'ai dit
dans mon intervention de la co-écriture
de ce texte du terrain vers le Parlement
et le travail parlementaire a permis de
je crois d'enrichir ce texte mais je
pense que le résultat de ce vote est
aussi dû et je l'en remercie à notre
rapporteur à Emer Duma qui a je crois
beaucoup contribué à ce que nous soyons
dans
une vision positive de ce texte donc je
voulais lui dire ici à la commission
bien sûr et à son président euh les
amendements qui nous inquiétait et dont
je parlais dans mon intervention ayant
été repoussés certains des nôtres ayant
été adoptés nous sommes d'autant plus
heureux de pouvoir voter ce texte tel
qu'il ressort de nos travaux néanmoins
je crois quand même mes chers collègues
ça a été dit hein mais qu'il ne faut pas
non plus faire dire à ce texte plus que
ce qui n'y est écrit et ce texte n'a pas
vocation à à à détruire enfin à réduire
à néant le chômage de longue durée sur
l'ensemble du territoire et en ce sens
le titre tel qu'il a été modifié je
crois apporte un peu plus de modestie à
ce texte et je crois que c'est bien
parce qu'il ne faudrait pas apporter de
l'insatisfaction au aux personnes qui
souffrent de ce fléo qui est le le
chômage de longue durée donc je pense
que nous faisons œuvre utile car toute
mesure qui pourrai
combattre de quelques milliers de de de
cas le chômage de longue durée c'est
positif hein 2 à 3000 nous disait madame
la rapporteur c'est ça de de bien mais
je suis persuadé je l'ai dit et je le
reste persuadé que c'est quand même bien
le secteur marchand qui doit être
créateur d'emploi et je pense qu'il y a
besoin et nous sommes ici au groupe CRC
très souvent porteur de propositions en
ce sens il y a besoin ici de redonner à
notre pays une industrialisation forte
et de vraies mesures pour l'emploi qui
ne soit pas seulement des mesures en
faveur des
entreprises merci Monsieur
Chassin présidente madame la ministre
bon on attendait quand même pas avec ce
texte de résorber le chômage de longue
durée bon c'est un petit plus je trouve
que c'est bien qu'on s' soit qu'on soit
associé à ce texte je remercie donc
madame le
rapporteur je regrette que dans l'avenir
même si c'est pas immédiat le secteur
marchand ne soit pas associé j'espère
qu'il qu'il le sera
euh ce projet ça sera j'espère dans
certains territoires que je connais bien
ruraux j'espère une dynamique
territoriale qui qui aurait nécessité
effectivement l'intégration dans ce
dispositif des artisans et commerçants
ça dit par Madame malerme qui ont très
peu de marge et qui pour certains
peuvent embaucher mais
on hésite à embaucher surtout des
chômeurs de longue durée parce que bon
ils ont des fois quelques a priori et
aussi bien sûr les charges sont fortes
et la flexibilité est
réduite donc je pense que ça aurait été
un plus pour intégrer le le secteur
marchand pour qu'il y ait vraiment une
dynamique dans le des territoires qui
vont être retenus néanmoins
effectivement je suis favorable j'ai
voté bien sûr à essayer de ce texte et
dans mon département dans ma commune
également merci merci il n'y a plus de
demande d'explication de vote donc je
vais mettre au voix l'ensemble de la
proposition de loi dont l'intitulé est
ainsi rédigé proposition de loi
d'expérimentation territoriale visant à
résorber le chômage de longue durée qui
est
pour non non non non qui est
contre qui
s'abstient cette proposition de loi est
adoptée je vous
remercie voilà pour l'adoption à
l'unanimité de cette proposition de loi
socialiste vous l'aurez noté un certain
nombre de groupes politiques au Sénat la
droite ou encore les communistes ont
jugé l'expérimentation proposée limitée
mais cela ne les a pas empêché de voter
favorablement il y a eu donc un certain
nombre d'amendements du Sénat qui ont
été adoptés à l'occasion de l'examen de
ce texte noté d'abord l'intitulé même du
texte qui a été modifié dans la version
de l'Assemblée nationale il s'agissait
d'une proposition de loi visant à faire
disparaî paraître le chômage de longue
durée des territoires le Sénat a été
plus modeste et certainement plus
réaliste et pour lui il s'agit
simplement d'une proposition de loi
visant à résorber le chômage de longue
durée le Sénat qui a également tenu à
inscrire dans le texte qu'il y aurait un
comité scientifique indépendant en
charge de l'évaluation de cette
expérimentation vous pouvez toujours
voir et revoir toutes les séances sur
notre site
publsenat.fr prochain rendez-vous de
l'actualité parlementaire cet après-midi
à 16h30 avec Sena 360 très bonne journée
sur les chaînes
parlementaires